- [Man] How have President
Reagan's policies affected
the government since he left office?
- What Ronald Reagan did was
set up a titanic debate really
between those who believed
in the new deal view
of government which was that
it was there to help those
who could not help themselves
and manage an enormous economy
and the enormous life of
the world's only superpower
or at least one of the two
superpowers and what that,
on the new deal style, that
was what government should do.
On the Reagan side, he said
get government out of the way
and let American free enterprise
and individual initiative
create greatness in America again
and so that was just setting
up that idealogic conversation
now continued all the way
through New Gingrich's revolution
in 1994 and his clashes with Bill Clinton.
They were over the same kinds
of things that Ronald Reagan
had brought into the debate
when he was elected in 1980.
Now the challenge was that
Reagan's defense spending
and his tax cuts ballooned the deficit
and what that ended up,
what ended up happening is that the thing
he had come to Washington to try to solve,
which was the budget deficit
had actually gotten bigger,
and so Reagan, who came to
town as a tax cutter ended up
ultimately having to raise taxes
to solve some of those problems
of having a large deficit
and why is that bad?
Because deficits lead to
inflation and inflation
is what was strangling America
when Reagan came into office.
Inflation was very high
and unemployment was high
and so, his solution to
it while it kicked off
a strong economic recovery also
ballooned the deficit which
is a problem that is still
one they wrestle with today.